now to indonesia where a volcano on the
island of java is spewing more ash after
erupting on saturday at least 15 people
have been killed and thousands have fled
their homes the deadly outburst covered
homes and villages with ash and hot mud
dozens of people are missing and
officials expect the death toll to climb
the ongoing volcanic activity means
rescue operations have had to be
suspended officials say search efforts
will resume when the situation becomes
safer
correspondent gail mattis has more
moving at the speed of a racing car hot
gases and volcanic matter traveled up to
11 kilometers covering the ground around
mount zimeru within minutes 1 300 people
had to flee from their homes into
makeshift emergency shelters
it was suddenly dark then it started to
rain the rain mixed with the ashes i ran
to look for my child and husband the
muddy water was pouring out of my house
the majority of those affected are sand
miners and their families who live on
the slopes of jabba's highest mountain
authorities want them not to return to
their villages but somewhere desperate
to check on livestock and possessions
left behind
the death toll is expected to rise when
the search for bodies resumes
we've stopped looking for people who
died for now
because it's just too risky with this
much rain
it's possible that another mud flow
could form coming from the top
and that puts our rescue teams at great
risk
eruptions following torrential rains
have happened before at mount zimeru but
this time people were caught by surprise
indonesia's center for volcanology says
it warned officials days before the
eruption about increased volcanic
activity
well that report from gail mattis who
joins us now from the indonesian capital
of jakarta welcome gaog as you were
saying at the end of your report the
region is prone to volcanic activity how
was this weekend's event different
the key difference clearly is uh phil
that the number of casualties and the
number of people that have been injured
in this
recent outbreak the outbreak itself and
the reason how it came to this outbreak
is not that so much unusual for this
particular type of volcano every rainy
seasons you have outbreaks of this type
causing mud rivers to run from the top
of the volcano basically caused by the
rain and that is why the government has
now the local government has now issued
a warning that seeing that more rain is
to come that further outbreaks may be
expected
and why didn't the government react to
scientists warnings
oh you have a lively debate now in
indonesia and particularly in the east
of java
involving the regional government there
involving government agencies involved
involving for instance the will
kinetic institute that i've mentioned
in the report and the debate really is
about whether an effective warning
system is in place whether warnings have
been
issued and if so if whether they've been
issued to the right people there's talk
about a whatsapp group where this
warning or key warning has been issued
where some people say you know that was
just another message that was not the
efficient system that we need in with
such an active volcano uh one of the
most active volcanoes in the world
all right so uh talk us through the
rescue efforts if you would gail
uh clearly now there's a key focus on an
emergency shelter you have over a
thousand people who need immediate help
who have lost basically um their houses
and then the central government
basically has stepped in and has
promised uh people who are particularly
hard hit that they will be relocated to
a new village
that they that that will happen within
half a year and that they will also
receive compensation until their new
homes are being built all right thank
you so much for that uh georg
all the best